i'm talking today to juanita clarke who
is from the fdth council africa juanita
nice to talk to you a rare chance to
have a chat with you we're live here in
in warsaw very interesting you were
talking about some of the communities in
south africa that are taking the
initiative with fibre optic deployment
yes brian that's it's actually very
interesting you know we've been
deploying fiber optic infrastructure for
years along all the national routes and
along many of the metro routes and the
end users have been asking for years
where is this fiber optics and when are
they going to see the benefit of it and
in 2014 we had a couple of cases of
communities taking the lead writing
tenders adjudicating tenders selecting
operators
and
these communities are deploying their
own infrastructure and bringing ftth to
their neighborhoods it's really
fantastic that's amazing what led them
to do that i mean it's a real initiative
isn't it
absolutely i agree
in africa some of your drivers for ftth
are very different so we find that
security camera surveillance that uh
it's a bandwidth intensive application
is one of the bigger drivers you know
communities want security and they're
using fiber as a you know the as
deploying it all over for security
surveillance and while you're doing that
you might as well have the fastest
internet speeds available and all the
other applications and fantastic things
that ftth brings you of course yes of
course that's a good point and and just
talk about the wider region because
outside of that you must have some sort
of major challenges
yes cross-border penetration still a
challenge if you look at the maps of
africa you'll see that central african
regions still don't have the fiber optic
reach that they should have there's
several operators that are doing
fantastic things around that you know
they are really going all out to get
across the borders but we still have to
educate african governments and policy
makers and get them to open the borders
so that we can get
farther to everybody but you're seeing a
few initiatives by the sound of it are
you confident that you'll sort of
eventually get there and help africa
keep pace with the rest of the world i
don't think we have a choice we have to
because uh fibra has got such fantastic
benefits for continents like africa
it's exactly these communities you know
the poorer communities that will have
the most benefit out of ftth or fiber
simply because of e-education and
e-health and
you know it's really the poor that
benefit from it so if we can educate our
governments and get them to invest in
high bandwidth networks so that we can
support our rural communities they are
the ones that's going to reap the
benefits out of it
well good luck with it and thank you
very much for talking to us thanks for
having me brian so that was anita clark
a woman on a mission to bring ftth wider
into africa